muchas personas en francia hicieron
compras de última hora antes del inicio
del nuevo confinamiento si bien las
medidas no serán tan estrictas como las
anteriores las personas aún deberán
mostrar un permiso cuando salgan a la
calle y no pueden alejarse más de 10
kilómetros de donde viven para los
habitantes de parís es más de lo mismo
con el presión no hay problema es solo
un toque de queda lo que sí es molesto
es la restricción para aquellos que han
planeado fines de semana fuera de parís
como mucha gente estoy un poco enojada
especialmente por no poder viajar es eso
realmente lo que más me molesta pero
aquí no tenemos otra opción de ver a una
persona no habrá límites en la cantidad
de tiempo dedicado a la actividad física
y el toque de queda se ha extendido una
hora comenzando a partir de las 7 de la
noche los parques y jardines públicos
también permanecerán abiertos pero la
alcaldesa de parís advirtió que podrían
surgir medidas aún más estrictas si la
gente no respeta las reglas depende de
nosotros de forma inteligente y
obviamente con la prefectura de policía
y la policía nacional nos aseguraremos
de que no
la numeración es mi incumplimiento de
las normas de distanciamiento social
pero por definición obviamente tenemos
que abrir todos estos espacios
los funcionarios esperan que no se
repitan las multitudes que se reunieron
a lo largo de las orillas del río sena
que obligaron a la policía a intervenir
y enviar a todos a casa